[音楽]
んこれじゃどっっっああ
例えば皆さんは桑の葉3月とという実験御存知だろうか
でも僕も動画でしか見たことないんだけどもなんかこういろんなの効果が消えて混ぜ
たらバーンなるようなんですよ
あバンドでごめんという今日は科学者の方に来てもらっています
どうぞはいこんにちはああっ働いて完全に通っておりますよろしく
ああああああ
あーされ妻聞くんですけどもそうな歯磨き粉実験に何が危険なんですか
まず劇物を使えますのでマードックの一歩手前ですね
あぶな今日はちょっと劇別使うちょっとこともトナーの強いで
数選定の監修のもと安全に実験をさせていただきたいと思います今日はよろしくお願い
ですまあ
世話早速歯磨く実験子ど前回ば寒かったんでここでエラーになっていきたいとおもい
ます
よろしくれるはいねじゃあ呼びっ暗いうちはドクター始めというよりもドクター研修生
としてさせていただきます
撮影たいと思いますかねまずは大丈夫ですか
えーとまずは
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
ヨウ化カリウムないずに10日せないといけないですねなるほど
巻つかないかカジュアルさを感じでしょ
by じゃございません
当所これで一気に入れられるかどうかですね
カバラバスター
めちゃされませんまずで準備完了ですはいをリッター水入れて来い全部村で動かし
ましょうわかりました
[音楽]
bejean
言われましたカードを全部
開封してはいちょっと待っていてわかりましたら
はい
[音楽]
me
います
一致した
いやこんなに贅沢に使ったことないですこれ
要素 ta 目立つ高いあ酒井んだ
小沢空ける時に冷たくなるのですかそう
セキュリティですああいうすっ
爪等
山へ
びっくり夏とかいいですね良かったあまり体準備くっつけたままなんですけどね
[音楽]
ん
tar
mar
あそのままが咲くん
思います
さあ
た草を散らされはいい
て気になるとか八かゲーム飛ばすことが完了しました
ちょっと残っているもののかなり解けました
タイヤ伝えする姉としは
いよいよ火山化水素はこれ
あ
入れましょうかはいこれ切ってるなんですよそうですね
これが大変あんなものですので
フェブ風呂統合グルドつけてはいいいえ
思いますそれを持ってないですか
映像にかなり近くなると思って後ろ白い斑点になっています真っ白なん
気付かないで大人がショップにするフレーズマニュアル
えっいませんですねはいいろいろしゃい
ああったーーー次はここにいろてでいるわけですね
はいを機に入れないかは
都市ですか案外ですね
持っ
すごいめっちゃファイルいい
ローズ家官僚で戦線を見るからドッグ速ですよすぎるんだっていうされたし次は何を
するんですか
次は芯材
入れましょうはい4 l 限らずあばらずでいいです
甘酒茶屋です
[音楽]
voodoo
も後はう
やる事一つ
もうで可能です作業です8日限りも
はい物声ばはいあのーは起きるはずです
わーやはり緊張しまっていざ壊れると大変ある第二型なので緊張感大事でさぁ皆さん
緊張感ができます弱で実験で今から同館大きいわけなんですけども弄った後はどうする
見えた瞬間する離れること
逃げるということでうん
逃げるにも分かりました k 30は3000人
30001体だけで心の準備できましたん
入っています
ああふわぁでわっ
いいます
もう今日でもねはいっ
tee
ええええええ
さあぞありえそうだ
いやー
フォア wii
でええわー
web tan
no 4汚れやん
[音楽]
wh
tee
me
[音楽]
yeah
teal
me
ana あああっ
うわぁ
何がどうなってんだこれん
すごすぎたーー
何がどうなってるんだこれをかけてみます位
ならないおすごい
ちょそっち行っていいです
えええええええ
と思う数後はまた凄いことに
是非作っにゃんこれはメッセ合意します
うわぁ
ザッカーグ区
風提供ありがとうございますありがとうございましたちょっとなったと熱すぎて
びっくりしたんですけどあーもうセミナーで薄め水蒸気がそうだったんですよねこれ
ホントあのやってること実は結構危ないかもしれないので皆さんやらないか今日は本当
にありがとうございました
また面白い月あったら教えてください宜しくお願